fue un primer día intenso para el Papa
Francisco en el inicio de su viaje
apostólico número 40 en la República
democrática del Congo fue es recibido
por decenas de miles de personas que
salieron a las calles de quinchas a la
capital para aclamar al pontífice
después del aterrizaje el papa se
dirigió luego al palacio de la nación en
donde se reunió con el presidente y
pronunció su primer discurso el
pontífice denunció el colonialismo
económico y político en África un
continente un continente que considera
víctima de todas las formas de
explotación por parte de las grandes
potencias económicas del planeta
Francisco también exhortó a la clase
política del país a la transparencia a
trabajar en favor de los intereses del
pueblo El Papa continuará Esta visita
con una importante misa este miércoles
Se esperan más de un millón de personas
de ser así sería la misa más grande
celebrada en África desde el inicio del
pontificado